I got owned like jumpscares but like I
like ghosts I believe today we're gonna
read some creepy things that kids have
said I do not have any children I do not
have children I'm still a child myself I
do not have kids but one day I do want
kids my three-year-old son was softly
singing while he was coloring already
hate that I don't like when kids sing
I stopped to listen but I'd never heard
the song before I asked where he learned
it and he said the lady in my bedroom
sang it to me I'm about to close his
[ __ ] spells this is how all horror
movies start children are pretty good
vessels for ghosts so that child is
probably haunted when I was about four
my mom found me in the bathroom was all
my Barbies making the book facedown in
the bathtub when she asked what I was
doing I replied the man in the wardrobe
told me if I didn't do it it would be my
turn to swim face down do these people
like still live in these houses bad kid
has got it like poltergeist infestation
- god these poor children my
three-year-old son and I were walking in
a crowded mall he likes to say hi to
everyone
creepy but normal he started hi hi hi as
people walked by but out of nowhere he
pointed at a man and said you're going
to die and then he continued with his
hellos what is with these Grim Reaper
kids look if an adult came up to me was
like hey you're gonna die I bet I'd
screw you man I'm not gonna die but if a
child came up to me and told me I was
gonna die I'd be like say my good-byes
I'd be reading my last rites I wonder if
his voice changed - like I hope that man
went to a doctor I worked at a summer
camp and one day I was playing with this
kid who was jumping off things and onto
me I said hey be careful if you kill me
I can't play anymore
he looks me dead in the eyes and said no
but I can play with you kids are creepy
I woke up to find my three-year-old son
lying in bed next to me I asked how he
got in my bed and he said he came to
protect me from the light eyes that were
standing over me while I was sleeping
hello creepy but also hella cute because
you know the kid wanted to protect his
mom this guy's creepy with the cause I
was babysitting a family friend's kid
and it was just the two of us in the
home she looked around and whispered to
me were not alone in this house what the
hell is wrong with these kids I would
hire a priest I've definitely seen this
scary movie
my mother was babysitting my daughter
while I was at a doctor's appointment
and said oh no grandma
Mama's not coming anymore today she was
in a bad bad accident she can't come get
us I had indeed been in an accident that
almost killed me at that exact time none
of my family had yet been notified
I guess maybe having a child is good
because they can warn you of these
dangerous things in the future
this kind of kid this is the one I want
because I feel like it wouldn't know if
I'd wake up in the morning and be like
hey Chad should I go to work and he'll
but something Bad's gonna happen I mean
that's enough for me and I'll call it a
sick death I was babysitting and didn't
know how to turn off the TV so it was
just static my 4 year old cousin stared
into the static and said I see the
monster that's what the child said this
is the ring I hope they're still alive
we're on a boat on vacation and my 4
year old cousin got really close to me
and whispered in my ear I want to be a
doctor so I can watch children die that
child has never heard of the Hippocratic
oath what I seriously consider tipping
the child over the boat yes hell yes
honestly I don't know if I want kids
anymore after this hell no I don't want
kids after reading this not only are
they sticky and germ filled but they're
also just dangerous
I was the creepy kid but I didn't know I
was like I don't know like six or seven
it was like it was weird cuz um I lived
in this house in Texas my sister was a
baby she slept in a crib still she had
her room or whatever so my parents put
her to bed one day and I was playing on
the top of the staircase and then I
looked down and I thought I saw my
sister crawling like to word me on the
floor she looked identical to my sister
but her eyes were like bigger and
blacker she was like whitish and she's
still crawling and I started screaming
for my parents and like I watched them
run into the room but when I looked back
it's gone so then I go to I like go to
India every couple years so when I
turned I remember because when I turned
18 I went there and then then my grandma
was braiding my sister's hair and we
have like weird cultural things you know
so my grandma was like she looks at my
mom who was also in the room but she's
like oh we're through that's really
funny her hair parted to the left so
that means her twin would have been a
girl so I was like what are you talking
about and my mom goes I never told you
but I miscarried your sisters twin so it
was like oh okay yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you